I started being interested in math originally
in connection to the Math Olympiads.
In Paris they instituted The Instituto Nacional
de Matemática Pura e Aplicada, Institute
for Pure and Applied Math here.
It's mostly a research institute.
It's very receptive for young people, so I
started here already straight from the Olympiads,
so still in high school.
At IMPA, dynamical systems is a very big part,
and one researcher here started talking to me.
I started liking the problems, and I started
doing dynamical systems after.
One example of a dynamical system includes
this kind of billiards that are very simplified
mathematical models.
You have a ball that moves and reflects elastically
off the boundaries.
They can consider something like a regular
pentagon, instead of rectangular billiards.
And you ask: What are the properties of these
dynamical systems?
So: What happens to the long-term behavior
of the particle?
You could ask what's the difference between
the different polygons.
From the point of view of dynamical systems,
you are looking at the whole global parameter
space.
One day I realized that some of the things
that I had computed at the technical level
for this kind of more usual analysis that
was available, what I tend to call one-frequence
shredding operators, was possibly unlocking
the possibilities to having a view of the
whole parameter space.
I knew that there were things that needed
to be done on the technical side, but now
it was within the realm of the possible.
Right now, I spend part of my time in Paris,
part of my time here in Rio.
I like to work in a nice setting — walking
along the beach.
You just hear the waves, and you can just
forget about all of the noise and so on.
I was surprised when I heard that I got the
prize.
The president of the IMU sent me an email
asking for a phone number, that she needed
to contact me.
In this moment I understood that it is likely
about the prize.
I felt very happy.
Most of all, more relaxed at that moment.
Of course it's good for both Brazil and France.
Brazil never had Fields medal or Nobel Prize.
I think it's very motivational for many people
here.